my name is Samir Dutta I'm a junior
studying computer science and minoring
and economics and this past year I've
been working with the MIT trade lab to
apply machine learning and data analysis
techniques in order to try and figure
out trends in a database of over 10
billion taffert observations so a few
interesting things to consider is like
you can see in these six graphs here
this is just for six country pairs you
can see a lot of variation in tariff
rates and our goal was to try and
introduce economic and political factors
into a machine learning model to try and
predict changes in these tariff rates as
you might expect the economic and
political intuitions are qualitative and
in order to get accurate machine
learning models you kind of need
quantitative continuous variables and so
a large part of the part of this project
was to take economic variables such as
negotiation power and quantify them into
measures that we can use in models so
for example a few factors that we found
were very correlated and and important
were democratic the democratic level of
a country the whether or not it's in a
trade war and how the health of the
economy is doing relative to previous
years and we were actually able to use
all these factors to develop a model
that had over eighty percent accuracy in
predicting tariff rates